[Music]  hi honey and McShane and today I'm  testing candles empire pine sage and hay  vybrid this Napoleonic camp with accents  a wild juniper bush a time of peace  right after a battle between dog and  wolf Madeleine galloping for Versailles  to Marseille Madeline's audacious spirit  trails in the wind this swashbuckling  fragrant pays homage to Madeleine de  mapa accomplished horse woman fencer and  renowned 17th century discipline  spiritus sancti splinters of crimson  gold and only Panamanian holy perfume of  altar candles the jury US wake of the  senses and perfume burners but you will  inquire the holy sense rise into the  soul  [Music]  like a chimp take all three just looking